I never got a Taekwondo feel like row
after seeing your high body don't do any
sport y'all win hike you seen this
little thought on the mountain bro it
was muddy but god damn I heard somebody
say who brought the transgender strip or
hiking mudskipper mudskipper shark I'm
freaking human I said what should I wear
is it nice to hike dude you're on a hike
I'd say you're gonna [ __ ] party in
WeHo what the road are you where your
help
he said just wear some soccer style
stuff you'd have to blow out your hair
for the hike I did 270 yards of mud come
on it's all mud and he's packing him up
he's on a four-wheeler he's totally cool
and comfortable
he has dog his hunting dog thrive yes me
Eagles he has a temper he's testing the
mud to make sure it's the temperatures
okay I was raised in the mud
[Laughter]
[ __ ] yeah bro it almost blew my back out
walking up all that mud yeah we'll get
you back Oh shouts my boy suplex and
Philly shout-out to nobody do there's no
[ __ ] I should call the cops on your
ass
zoom in hey super he's built like a Lego
piece covered in cheese yeah far away he
looks like [ __ ] Billy get in there
bro that's the man's body right out of
my [ __ ] back after walking up all
that mud I was straight up when I got up
there you idiot
I was very dancing look at my look at
the dislocation Joe dislocated my damn
rekt or something
dislocated your lower body from your
upper body
don't take me on that [ __ ] wrote it on a
regular my favorite part is you had
those brand-new brand-new shoes my house
they
wrecked the wreck man here's the worst
part though so we hide dude hold on
before he does the story I had to take
the easy path for this [ __ ] it's like
an lesbian aunt over here on the high
brow the shortcut shortcut yeah because
you're wearing hiking stuff dude try
doing it in [ __ ] cheerleading [ __ ]
that's the only [ __ ] I had in my car
with some men's you're kind of a younger
man's kind of clothing that's what I had
you said it was where soccer like a tire
well it was a at least at least probably
a mile of mud just uphill mud hello was
all hi oh I remember them six months you
ever seen a passion of the christ' you
ever seen that
now imagine that in mud and short joints
my epoxy body's gonna suppose mildly say
that he imagined Passion of Christ he
was a gingerbread man I do that
gingerbread Behati bra I'll pull out
that straight-up [ __ ] G bred physique
son rage you know what I'm sayin huh I
told y'all I'm built like a Conestoga
wagon you freak I'm built like a damn
basement freezer no but what you want up
that [ __ ] caboose thought he was just
cruising every time they take a piece of
coal and just put it in my butt
well here's the warm-up bro you're
moving as if this [ __ ]
Oregon Trail of brendensen couldn't get
any shittier so first of all the guy
takes me on this [ __ ] thing I thought
I was gonna get raped at one point very
sketchy very sketchy and even one of the
past it was like the the Natalie
Holloway very alarming for a mountain so
I was like what is this and the Sun have
been made by Brendan you knew it had
been because Holloway was misspelled
okay who is it
Oh
so first of all yeah cuz I wasn't here I
wasn't equipped for the thing I freeze
dire early man tell your trainers to
quit pushing that [ __ ] ain't working I
wasn't equipped for this kind of [ __ ]
you idiot when people ask you for
information you have to give them
information you can just say something
doesn't make any sense dude I was like
how's it gonna be muddy can we hike
today is it safe out there yeah man
we're something soccer style soccer
style this is one of you or hey well
here's the worst part it looks like that
I couldn't found someone [ __ ] [ __ ]
hey dude don't worry part your [ __ ]
Subaru Outback
so we park Brendon instead of walking to
the freakin front of the hike this has
to drive us to the front of the high
okay and immediately then I've I can
make sure I had my rape whistle in my
pocket okay that's the first clue of a
freakin sex offender somebody's gonna
drive you up a hike
so we get partially up the height and so
he parks we get out we walk out we walk
up the hike so then he takes us down
some back way in the shortcut right this
whole [ __ ] ants ooh over here couldn't
keep going dude I always blew out my
[ __ ] occipital --hz man delinquents
your absent plants was huh
my cossacks was [ __ ] rocked bro
because you couldn't put me on level
ground or at least just tell me to be
prepared do I need a walking stick all
of this nah nah man quit being a little
[ __ ] okay here's the worst part so we
get off of the hill okay we get off of
the bucket whatever this was dude this
Malvo Lance
so Mountain it was flowing the blood was
and I ride my bike up brother for
hedgehogs went by in a boat in a Pierrot
that they made out of a piece of birch
so anyway we get off the hike we into a
neighborhood I'm like well this is we
were even going we keep walking I'm like
a we close he's like a man we're almost
there we keep hiking for about another
25 minutes to Brendan's house bruh so we
get there and I'm like you what are we
doing here shortcut where's the car and
he's like oh [ __ ] man
Oh we [ __ ] drove there and then I go
you forgot yeah yeah no I get I think
this Gorge does and then I go dude just
give me a ride back my car dude goes my
keys so that is the last time I don't
check TripAdvisor bro he's wearing huge
dog booties wearing those big waffle
things on damn boots man yeah this guy's
gotta be out there like can't hangs it's
got me struck dude your struggle City oh
stop look like a stripper on ice
[Music]
nothing
[Music]